[Music]
if that is the way to make AI implode
it's just
[Music]
so uh be apparent
AI Godfathers guy's name is Jeffrey
Geoffrey Hinton he warns of the dangers
of AI as he quits Google Now caveat he
is 75 so it's basically time to retire
anyway oh he is now literally and he's
been deemed in the AI space as like the
kind of Godfather who created like the
framework and the foundation for what
turned into things like Chad gbt and XYZ
right then why'd he do it stupid ass
yeah it's his fault if he already knew
it was bad he shouldn't have released it
[__] idiot I know Bozo [__] this guy
this guy isn't stupid the biggest idiot
ever I know and then he's gonna die and
he's like I missed something very bad
it's my fault that's what he's gonna say
yeah why do you put on every single USB
drive if he [__] knew it bad to begin
with stupid idiot is this an ironic
story where like he's getting pushed out
of his own job by AI
you are fired yeah it's still talks like
that yeah so I got beef even though we
have Siri who has a regular voice and
different accents fired for that Tick
Tock voice what's that Tick Tock female
voice that everyone used oh yeah
decided to blah blah blah blah blah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's kind of hot though
kind of hot a little bit yeah [__] her
for sure I'll be beating those cheeks up
a little bit
um so he says right now they're not more
intelligent than us as far as I can tell
but I think they soon may be and to his
point you think about like the average
intelligence of people and you think
about something like like chat gbt which
is very very relevant right now the
average intelligent people are already
dumb as [__] well AI just passed dancer
brains like just past it wow really it's
in the last like six months damn that
was that's the article for this is it
right yeah well no I'll do I'll do it to
her what bear article which one bear
playing piano there's a couple airplane
drums
this isn't there a thing saying that
like the the distance between like an
idiot and Einstein was like some
double-digit amount of IQ and the
distance between Einstein's IQ and AI is
like five thousand percent oh my God I'm
willing to bet AI is smarter than most
oh for sure yeah okay here's the thing
here's the thing that paints a picture
in concept that makes it really
um understandable why it's going to be
way smarter than us way faster right all
of us as individuals as human beings
we're all separate human beings right
whereas AI across the network
AI across the network are in essence
like a copy of the same thing anytime I
learn a new piece of information we have
to congregate in order for me to share
that knowledge whereas with AI anytime
one of them learns a new piece of
information all of them have the new
knowledge simultaneously plus we're
human beings if you say you know
something I'm gonna say you don't know
and I don't even know
yeah yeah baby because we're human
[__] you know my gut tells me you
don't know [__] yeah that's what I'll
say yeah my dad says that you're you
don't even you don't even know yeah but
Dad yeah
paragraph I'm just I'm just comment cap
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay deal with that sure use this
comment for dislikes yeah
use me as a dislike button yeah maybe
maybe that's what stops AI is just
internet trolls just [__] being real
hey I can't handle it yeah yeah they're
like oh ai's gonna go cannot compute
yeah dude we're good if that is the way
to make AI implode it's just just be a
human yeah they're like I can't [__]
I don't know what to do yeah exactly
will AI be able to understand that what
this person is they'll be like why are
you doing that a troll right yeah it
doesn't understand the sure okay
yeah but then responding to sure okay
with four paragraphs
that means the troll owns your brain
dude the troll owns you right dude oh
man that's what AI would do and then AI
would keep responding and like not
knowing too long did it read but wait
until they make troll GPT
[Laughter]
people don't forget yeah I Spit on some
old teacher cancer patients car I
wouldn't do this it was AIDS all right
it was a cancer
[Laughter]
oh my but of course it is perceivable
that it's human nature that somebody's
going to use this technology for
evil teeds right yeah yeah as all of us
would basically BET our lives on the
fact that somebody's gonna use this tech
for bad things they're probably doing it
now hell yeah you should use it now for
a Bad Thing what's the best way to uh
exist without it Off the Grid style
living and how long can we do that until
Black Mirror [__] comes where the AI can
take robot form and then come [__] with
you that's the thing I mean the most uh
I think the upper people that are like
trying to do something about it we've
kind of talked about this before on the
show too is that they want to put in
place a regulatory agency so that it
doesn't go out of hand too quickly right
because if there's no regulation on it
it's just gonna [__] go Bonkers and
that sounds for sure don't you feel like
those same people are still going to be
using it though for the for their own
gains while at the same time going and
don't use it guys it's bad definitely
don't we have like um agencies to
prevent like too much power oh you're
right we have checks Disney buys Fox and
[__] like it's just one big company
yeah you're right nobody says anything
about it like yeah okay but we love
Disney that's true I do love Disney you
love Disney I just hope the uh DMV isn't
the one in charge of running yeah you
heard that new agency you know maybe
space force or some other new one that's
good
space force news has been kind of quiet
we haven't heard much have you seen how
like have you seen that thing that uh
David Cho said about his lawyer and how
he fired him because his lawyer
basically gave the same answers as Chad
GPT no way wait what do you mean because
he had legal questions to ask and then
he was like I'm gonna go ahead and test
it and ask my lawyer at the same time
while typing into chat gbt yeah and he
basically had the same answer so he goes
why am I paying this guy a retainer yeah
because the lawyer actually wrote in
chat2 and got the answer
did it so he was like what's the point
of that he watched a tick tock video on
how to be more efficient with AI and
then the lawyer is like oh that's true
yeah because he's I think like
especially if you're paying by the hour
he he was like saying it's such a waste
when you have to call someone and then
talk about how your kids how's your day
how's this your job and all this extra
[__] he's like just get to the point so
I do hate small talk I [__] despise
small talk if AI fixes a small talk
problem that'd be huge Small Talk GPT
[Laughter]
you know what I
what I hate first paragraph that they
have to let you know I am AI so I don't
know this and this and this I'm like I
[__] know that you're ruining your
credit you know you're an AI That's like
when I'm on the plane like okay so in
the event of a water landing I'm like
I'm flying from Las Vegas to L.A there's
no water landing unless we go into
somebody's pool dude but they're like
you gotta take the thing and put it over
there land on the Bellagio though but
like why do we need all that every time
I click I
[__] off
just roll down yeah just accept accept
it because also too it's like if a plane
crashes and you're the guy that didn't
watch the safety briefing and you drown
hey dude I'll take the L like that's
that's not me that's true my bad no
one's like the guys who are sitting in
the emergency exit Rose and like sir can
you take out remove your headphones
please you need to take this movement
very seriously I'm going to need you to
agree to be a leader in a moment and
it's like bro the guy is just like I
want leg room [__] you I just want my
group
like [__] you and also if the plane goes
down you this guy's gonna be a leader
he's gonna be like I swore to that
[__] stewardess
I gave her my [__] word like give me
a break dude pushing people out of the
way so he can be first out dude
what is that it's like there's so much
AI in Flight like technology that
eventually air traffic is just gonna be
completely my buddy automated air
traffic my buddy's a pilot that he does
take takeoffs and landings and that's it
and then they just chill yeah everything
is autopilot at that point right oh damn
because then you know like the air
traffic controller isn't that one of the
most stressful jobs like in yeah my
brother did that yeah oh my God he got
out of it because it's too too crazy
really he almost had a collision one
time on the tarmac not like in the air
but on the tarmac where two planes were
like almost gonna hit each other yeah
communication he's like this is too
stressful it's because one guy was
Croatian the other one's Chinese yeah
that was one they didn't know English
great Chinese that could happen yeah but
if that was AI that seems like it would
be a lot better like easier to navigate
right that's only AI doesn't make
mistakes until it makes every play and
just yeah until that moment of
Singularity where it's like D-Day right
where they all just decide to like end
us jeez what do we need AI for really
anyway bro paralegals are fun to make
crafted.com articles yeah admin dude
admin work and like a lot of that kind
of [__] the filler stuff yeah like
what were the top Star Wars movies of
all time oh dude watch Mojo well we were
also talking about the [__] uh the AI
link that I think Joe sent in our text
about like editing podcasts and stuff
like that
that's amazing that's crazy right I
downloaded some of it it's still beta
though like cans [__] the fact that it
the fact that they had a vacuum behind
his head and it's still isolated his
voice because it wasn't recording it was
recreating what it thinks he's saying
well even we're [__] insane like if it
gets good enough which is already
getting there you could already see
Kanye singing songs he never made it
could be like uh what would the careful
boys say about no AI is gonna know what
you're ever gonna say no AI is going to
be able to they already did a Joe Rogan
and Hitler conversation yeah that [__]
was crazy what was it like Joe Rogan's
predictable I think he's gonna talk
about Ayahuasca he's going to talk about
Ancient Aliens no nobody knows where
you're gonna go with your cold questions
on Hot Seat no no that's true you don't
you don't even know I don't even know
that's true halfway through the sentence
he doesn't even know what he's gonna say
[Music]
foreign